Emma Thompson clever funny mad as a
chair that's true you know him yes In
fairness yeah
ready zalberger delightful all so far
from sane
fair then we get into a run of these
Julianne Moore brilliant actress loads
me yes Rachel Vice clever beautiful
despises me yes Drew Barrymore made her
cry hates me
that can't be true
um Julian definitely hates me hey Rachel
Weiss I think we got on fire I don't
know why I said that maybe I was going
for a comedy triple I don't know who was
the third one uh Drew Barrymore she made
the mistake of giving me notes which how
would you take that
acting with someone else very well
didn't I
why was that